throughout its seven seasons Michael
Shores delightful workplace comedy
Brooklyn nine-nine has introduced
audiences to an incredibly fun cast of
characters unlike anything else on
television there's something for
everybody to love in the nine-nine but
we can't forget about one of the show's
most beloved characters Gina linetti
played by comedian chelsea peretti
Gina linetti is pure it constantly
drawing attention to our extremely high
self-esteem and super specific world
view all while making audiences laugh
with her bold antics and distinctive
attitude pretty cool right watch this
milk milk lemonade around the corner
fudge is made
that is amazing isn't it despite Gina's
overwhelming popularity however Peretti
made the seemingly unexpected decision
to leave the show in its sixth season if
you're wondering why Ferretti ensure
ended Gina's journey within the show
early and what Peretti is up to now
we've got you covered once it was
announced that Peretti would be leaving
Brooklyn nine-nine Gina in the show
delivered one last time in the season
six episode four movements
Gina employs her dance skills and sense
of drama to say an individual goodbye to
each member of the precinct producing an
episode that's just as hilarious as it
is moving yes there's nothing more
empowering than getting a condescending
colleague to do a menial task for you in
an interview with The Hollywood Reporter
Purdy opened up about the process behind
her farewell episode and why it was the
right time to leave indicating that the
decision was made jointly among herself
executive producer Dan gore and sure
well it wasn't just a solo process I
wasn't just like I'm leaving and I swing
my cape I think it came together this
was the time to do it it's not always
easy to make changes in life but I feel
like everyone came to a point where
everyone was like okay this is the time
Freddy also dished up details on the
episode itself saying that she had
plenty of creative control when it came
to Gina's grand goodbye I had a lot of
input me and Dan spent a lot of time on
the phone cackling about a variety of
different ideas not all of them made it
but we did have a lot of fun though
Peretti clearly loved playing Gina as
she told The Hollywood Reporter she was
surprised and gratified to find that her
character had helped women become more
confident it was time for her to move on
and try something new
which is exactly what this versatile
comedian did though she also told thr
her next moves include quote running for
president of the United States or a
senator Ferretti has stuck to comedy in
the season six episode called The Return
of the King Gina made a brief return is
a full-fledged celebrity ever since then
she stayed out of Brooklyn and worked on
other projects and she has a very
diverse resume to back her up
beretti has appeared in films like pop
star never stopped never stopping and
game night
she's also lent her voice to projects
like big mouth American Dad Harvey girls
forever Adventure Time Crank Yankers
and rise of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles over the years as well as a
two-episode spent on The Simpsons in
2019 give that back that's for Skinner's
office recently Peretti embarked on a
new venture that would probably make
Gina linetti pretty proud in April 20 20
unexpectedly announced that she was
starting a new career in music the
ensuing EP foam and flotsam which she
dropped shortly after a lengthy
announcement is a conceptual mini album
about coffee shops it features her
Brooklyn co-star Terry Crews and
comedian Reggie Watts among others and
features songs with titles like late
sound proof and oat milk Ferretti even
recorded high concept music videos to go
along with several songs and her
super-serious approach to this super
silly material is just the icing on the
cake outside of her work Freddie has
also become a mother she and her husband
Jordan Peele welcomed Beaumont Geno
Peale into the world in July of 2017
Gina may not work at the nine-nine
anymore but if you want to relive her
glory days the entirety of Brooklyn
nine-nine is streaming on hulu check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]